[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
conversamos con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia y
asesor científico de france24 doctor qué
bueno tenerlo nuevamente con nosotros
avanza la campaña de vacunación en el
mundo pero poco se sabe aún de la
vacunación para los niños que podemos
decir de los avances de las
investigaciones para inocular a esta
población
son buenas noticias raúl porque hoy se
han anunciado en estas semanas el avance
de estudios en donde empiezan a
reclutarse niños para poder llevar a
cabo los estudios de las vacunas son
resultados hasta ahora alentadores y muy
probablemente un poco tengo en poco
tiempo tengamos las indicaciones dos
estudios uno que se toma población de 12
a 16 años y otro de 6 a 12 años están en
desarrollo y estamos esperando esos
resultados que se harán un par de meses
y seguramente con eso se avanzará a la
recomendación de la vacunación en los
infantes doctor justamente se registró
la noticia del primer bebé que nació con
anticuerpos contra el coi 19 en eeuu es
este un caso anecdótico o resalta la
importancia de vacunar a las mujeres
embarazadas
y vacunar a las mujeres embarazadas es
seguro no es una contraindicación sea
advertir sobre algunos riesgos pero se
puede vacunar las mujeres embarazadas
estas noticias no solamente nos traen
buenas digamos un buen augurio porque es
que la mujer en masa no tenga coi pero
además de eso que el bebé nace con las
defensas y evitaría un kobe por lo menos
en su primera infancia
digamos que cada vez hay más información
certera de eso y va a ser una buena
noticia porque sobre todo en el tercer
trimestre donde se pueden complicar las
personas de kobe de embarazadas sería
una indicación para vacunar en un futuro
reciente y es que precisamente el
laboratorio janssen anunció que su
vacuna podría ser utilizada en mujeres
gestantes y lactantes es ésta la más
segura se ha investigado en la
vacunación en esta población con otros
fármacos doctor
janssen hace esta información basado en
sus análisis en sus estudios donde ha
recaudado datos acerca de esta población
e informa su seguridad esto seguramente
va a pasar con las otras casas
farmacéuticas pero jansen que es una
vacuna muy interesante porque es una
sola dosis con poca cadena de frío se
podría usar en este grupo de población y
seguramente así va a ser la indicación
en los países donde esté aprobada el uso
de esta vacuna en algunos de américa
latina en este futuro reciente también
ahora que podemos decir de la necesidad
de vacunar a las personas con cáncer o
con inmunodeficiencias corren a un tipo
de peligro estas personas con las
vacunas
es una muy buena pregunta porque no hay
contraindicación para las personas con
cárcel o inmunosupresión la vacuna no
hace daño hay que hacer algunos ajustes
en los tratamientos porque la
efectividad como obviamente tienen bajar
las defensas es un poco menor a lo
esperado en las personas que no tienen
estas enfermedades no hace daño la
vacuna se pueden vacunar y se deben
vacunar las personas con cáncer
inmunosupresión y se debe consultar al
médico para hacer los ajustes de
tratamiento cuando sean pertinentes pero
este es un llamado para que ellos se
vacunen en una forma segura ya se está
haciendo y no ha pasado nada doctor
también por último le quiero preguntar
que entonces le dice a las personas
sanas que todavía tienen dudas sobre la
vacunación era mejor también con la
vacuna de astrazéneca que ha presentado
pues al en algún tipo de contratiempo
con un coágulo de sangre algunos
pacientes inyectados con este fármaco
digamos que en el momento no se
establece una relación de causalidad con
que la vacuna astrazéneca produzca
embolismo y la información de la ms y lo
que hoy sale en emea muy probablemente
haya una relación pero no una causalidad
de la vacuna recordemos que los
fenómenos de embolismo y la tercera
causa mortalidad en el mundo y no va a
desaparecer por la vacuna entonces
pueden ser efectos concomitantes pero un
paso importante las vacunas hay que
confiar ya son más de 260 millones de
personas vacunadas no se han registrado
fallecimientos por la vacuna ni por kobe
en las personas vacunadas así que
adelanté con la vacunación con confianza
y estar muy atentos a las noticias el
seguimiento para ver si hay algún cambio
en estas semanas así es doctor gracias
por su tiempo para estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 que tenga usted un
feliz resto de ustedes también gracias
por acompañarnos
[Música]